ein taschentuch frisch gebügelt rein
unschuldig und doch aufgeladen mit
gefühlen geschichten erinnerungen herta
müller während der feierlichkeiten zum
literatur nobelpreis 2009
sie beginnt ihre rede mit einer anekdote
es geht um etwas scheinbar gewöhnliches
etwas das auch in ihrem werk eine
überraschende rolle spielt hast du ein
taschentuch
ich hatte keine ich hatte jeden morgen
keine weil ich jeden morgen auf die
frage wartete das taschentuch war der
beweis dass die mutter mich am morgen
behütet jeden tag muss das mädchen
härter hinaus aufs feld um die kühe zu
hüten
mutterseelenallein bleibt sie dort bis
zum abend
viel zeit über das leben nachzudenken
dann ist man halt den ganzen tag mit
sich allein und ich habe mich dann halt
beschäftigt mit mit dem was vorhanden
war
auch die vergänglichkeit habe ich
begriffen ich hatte kein wort dafür ist
es besser wenn du verwurzelt ist und gar
nicht weg kannst oder ist es besser dass
ich gehen kann
1953 kommt herta müller im
deutschsprachigen teil rumäniens in
nitzkydorf zur welt ihre familie war in
rumänien enteignet worden
das leben ist entbehrungsreich für
sentiment ist wenig raum
trost spendet dem kind die tägliche
frage nach dem taschentuch in ihrem
berühmtesten roman atemschaukel erzählt
herta müller die geschichte des deutsch
rumänischen lyrikers oskar pastior der
wurde als zwangsarbeiter in ein
ukrainisches arbeitslager deportiert
gerade mal 17 jahre alt zum symbol der
hoffnung wird für ihn ein taschentuch
das schneeweiße taschentuch aus feinstem
byd ist bald so etwas schönes hatte ich
lange nicht mehr gesehen
die schönheit der normalen
gebrauchsgegenstände war zu hause nicht
der rede wert
im lager mangelt es an allem
menschlichkeit wärme brot der
ausgehungerte heranwachsende bettelt
heimlich bei den russen einmal bittet
ihn eine alte frau rein
ihr eigener sohn ist lang schon
verschwunden der junge zwangsarbeiter
erinnert sie an ihn ungewöhnlich
gastfreundlich macht sie dem fremden ein
geschenk
was da geschah ging weit über mich und
sie und ein taschentuch hinaus es betraf
ihren sohn
sie musste etwas tun für ihren sohn weil
ich da war und er von zu hause so weit
weg wie ich
die geschichte ähnelt dem schicksal von
herta müllers mutter jahrelang war diese
als junge frau zur zwangsarbeit in die
ukraine verband doch im hause müller
spricht man darüber nicht später in
georgia skus rumänien leidet auch herta
müller selbst und der politischen
sanktionen
der geheimdienst securid hatte versucht
dreimal sie als spitzel zu werben
sie lehnt ab und bezahlt dafür mit
verlust der arbeit todesdrohungen und
essens folter auf dem tisch waren hart
gekochte eier und grüne zwiebeln unsere
reuschel mit ganz groben grauen könig im
salz und dann musste ich esse ich glaube
ich musste acht eier essen und dann hat
er mir in den hintern getreten
ich bin dann so mit dem gesicht nach
vorne in einem gebüsch gefallen und dann
habe ich zuerst habe ich gekreuzt
diese ganzen reihe raus getrotzt und
dann habe ich mich halt abgewischt und
bin aufgestanden bin nach hause gegangen
rumänien wird unerträglich für sie 1987
gelingt ihr die ausreise mit ihrem
damaligen mann und ihrer mutter kommt
sie am wiener hauptbahnhof an
sie hat das regime überlebt
doch auch im westen wirft die securid
aber noch ihre schatten als cashcow 1989
gestürzt und zum tode verurteilt wird
kommt die endgültige erleichterung und
jetzt habe ich gedacht der typ ist
gestorben
nein gott er ist sterblich der ist jetzt
weg es hat auch nur eine kugel gebraucht
denn irgendwie hat man ja gedacht das
regime ist auch ewig das haben sie in
einem jahr jeden tag gesagt
im roman überlebt die hauptfigur die
brutalität des arbeitslagers gerettet
auch durch ein taschentuch viele male
hätte es getauscht werden können
doch immer stand es für die hoffnung auf
bessere zeiten
ich glaubte das taschentuch ist mein
schicksal wenn man sein schicksal aus
der hand gibt ist man verloren
ich schäme mich nicht wenn ich sage das
taschentuch war der einzige mensch der
sich im lager um mich kümmert